عجائب وغرائب الحوثيين واتباعهم مسلسل لا
ينتهي وجديد اليوم محاضر من قيادي
الحوثيين واقف في محاضره وقدام كمبيوتر
وبروجكتر واضح قدامه مليان حضور كمان
وبيحذر من الادويه الاجنبيه اللي قال انه
فيها نفط بترول وانه الهدف منا القضاء على
اليمنيين والعالم كمان
اي واحد يكتب عسل في امريكا وفي العالم
كامل يحبس فورا اللي قال الله عن الشباب
والقران اصبح تخلف
ويعني ويحبس اللي يكتبه
اصبحت يطب الرائج تم ترسيخ طب الادويه
الكيميائيه مصنوعه من سماه
النطق كل مصنوع من النفط
اشرب قاس بترول
تقبلوها ما عادش قابلها اليهوديه في غلاف
هكذا وجملها وحط عليها هذا اعلامي اصبحت
مقبوله ولا هو في في غلاف ماده كيميائيه
وصلت الحياه هكذا
عرفت في المحاضره في القاعه هذه تكلم محمد
شهاري الفيديو في اخر محاضره ان شاء الله
في الجوله الخامسه عشر في القاعه هذي في
المكان هذاك انه كان 11 حبه حق الضغط
والسكر والكوليسترول والكبد والدهون
والاشياء عجيبه
ولا حبه
ولا حبه بدون علاجات
شيء عجيب يعني بذمتكم هل طبيعي اللي
سمعناه بيتكلم بكل جديه كمان يعني الرجال
بيتكلم عن مؤامره ادواتها ادويه الضغط
والسكر وغيرها وسماها مصنوعات بتروليه
يهوديه مليانه سموم لاستهداف اليمنيين
والعالم اجمع لا وعرض صور كمان يعني وقال
لك هذا سبب زياده الامراض في العالم
التصريح متداول بشكل واسع وصاير حديث
الساعه او خلينا ادق يعني عشان نكون
دقيقين مسخره الساعه
التصريح صحيح من جديد عجائب وخرافات
الحوثيين لكن للاسف مو الاول ولا الوحيد
وبشركم التصريح متداول اليوم لكنه يعودنا
ندوه من كم يوم عنوانها خطوره اللقاحات
على البشريه حضرها قيادات الميليشيا وعلى
راسهم رئيس حكومه الحوثيين غير المعترف
بها دوليا عبد العزيز بن حبتور ووزير
الصحه طه المتوكل مدير مكتب زعيم المليشيا
كمان والكلمات في الندوه ركزت على انه
الطب الحديث واللقاحات عباره عن مؤامره
عدوانيه كل هذا في الوقت اللي بتشير فيه
التقارير والبيانات الانتشار ملحوظ
للادويه والاوبئه في مناطق سيطرتهم لانه
من محاربتهم طبعا لحملات التطعيم مثل
الحصبه والشلال ويعني خلاص دخلوا الان
مرحله التفشي يعني
[موسيقى]